Entre vous... émoi
- Bonjour, pour commencer je citerais Patrick Bosso qui disait;
''Pas de stress, y'a point S''
- Aujourd'hui, je reçois l'homme le plus cool du Monde.''
- Bonjour !
- Yo !
- Soyez le bienvenue ici,  Kevin.
- Tu sais tu peux me tutoyer "buddy".
- Ah bon ?
- Bah... euh ... merci...
Bah... du coup est-ce que tu vas bien Kév ?
- Voilà ! On est à la cool !
Vraiment, parle moi cool.
Heu, est-ce que tu vas bien ma poule ?
- Voilà, détend tes jambes papa.
Tranquille !
Bienvenue ici poto !
- C'est cool.
Mais comment ça ce fait que t'as changé de fringues  amigo?
- Parce qu'il se trouve que la salopette vient juste de devenir à la mode.
Okay wesh poto ! Hashtag bien vu, hashtag visionnaire de la mode, hashtag "OKLM".
- Ca te va bien la salopette.
C'est dommage que ça soit plus autant à la mode qu'à l'époque d'il y a 5 secondes.
Mister "too late".
Oh non ! Comment j'suis trop deg'
Bah du coup, comment on fait pour être " à la cool" ? Faut faire quoi d'autre ?
Bah déjà, s'arrêter de poser des questions.
Moi ce que je te propose, c'est que t'enlèves tes "shoes".
Mets tes pieds sur la table, et tu te mets à l'aise.
Ok, t'as raison.
Parce que comme j'ai des double-noeuds.
Oh et pi, j'les garde mes "shoes". Elles sont pas trop cool sans déconner ?
Elles sont trop cool, mon pote. Tu sais, si tu continues comme ça, tu risques de devenir encore plus cool que moi.
C'est vrai ?
Et ça, c'est plutôt "méga lol". Vivement vendredi, j'ai envie d'te faire un "follow friday".
C'est quoi ? Un "follow friday" ?
Tu connais pas Twitter ? The blue bird, man.
J'y vais dessus, mais pas hyper souvent.
J'aime bien t'es cool, parce que tu prends une complète distance avec les réseaux sociaux, et ça, ça me met dans un état d'extase.
Mais du coup, c'est quoi qui est pas cool pour toi ? C'est ça qui m'intéresse.
Les gens qui likent leur propre statut, ceux qui mettent des chaussures sans chaussettes,
les filtres sur Instagram, tous les Coca, sauf le Zero,  les requins blancs, le diesel,  les yaourts avec morceaux,
les pèse-personnes, la gastro, les boutons de manchettes, et surtout...
les phrases de plus de 60 mots.
Tu pourras compter, j'en ai dit 59.
Woaw ! Trop cool !
Bon écoute, c'est pas tout, mais là dans 20 minutes,  j'ai mon cours de zumba
Ca ! C'est le plus over cool, du cool, du cool !
Piégé !
La zumba n'a jamais été cool.
J'ai essayé de te tester et...
j'crois que tu m'as un peu déçu.
C'est dommage j'aurais voulu que tu sois aussi cool que moi.
Comment j'suis trop deg', j'me suis trop fait avoir.
Hashtag trop la honte, hashtag j'suis nul,  hashtag...
Allez !
Pousse les meubles.
Il est temps pour moi de faire le truc le plus cool du monde.
Des charades !
Non !
Du break dance.
Non, assis-toi. T'as laissé passer ta chance.
Bon bah c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
J'ai envie de vous donner rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
Je recevrai le champion du monde 2012, 2013 et 2014 de cache-cache.
Faudra d'abord me trouver !
Au revoir.